على رأس جدول الأعمال هنا في
منتدى الدوحة، الحرب بين إسرائيل وحماس
بالطبع، وكما نقلنا عن
التقارير، يشعر اللاعبون الإقليميون
بالإحباط المتزايد مع ارتفاع
عدد القتلى في غزة خلال ما يزيد قليلاً عن
شهرين، فقد قُتل أكثر من 18,000 شخص
وفقًا لوزارة
الصحة في غزة، يشعر الكثيرون أن الولايات المتحدة،
المورد الرئيسي للأسلحة إلى إسرائيل،
لا تفعل ما يكفي لوقف
إراقة الدماء بالأمس في المنتدى
هنا. لقد تحدثت مع وزيرة الخارجية الأردنية
إيمان الصفار، وكانت بلاده
عالية الصوت وثابتة في موقفها.  يدعو
إلى وقف إطلاق النار منذ الأيام الأولى
لهذا الصراع، كان في واشنطن مع
وزراء عرب آخرين يوم الجمعة يتحدث
إلى وزير الخارجية الأمريكي،
استمع إلى ما قاله
لي إن إسرائيل خلقت قدرًا من
الكراهية التي ستطارد هذه
المنطقة  ستحدد الأجيال
القادمة، وبالتالي فهي تضر
شعبها بقدر ما تلحق الضرر
بالجميع في المنطقة. هذه
حرب لا يمكن الفوز بها. لقد
عانت إسرائيل بالفعل من
هزيمة استراتيجية، والسؤال هنا اليوم هو ماذا
يحدث الآن وماذا يحدث  أم التالي هل
شعرت بتغيير في لهجة الإدارة الأمريكية سواء
في السر أو في
العلن من الإدارة الأمريكية
يعني ماذا ما هو الضغط الذي
أردت أنت ووزراء عرب آخرون أن
تمارسوه على واشنطن
أه بقدر ما  أه الضغط على الإسرائيليين
همهم فقط أوقفوا هذه الحرب أوقفوا
هذا الجنون أوقفوا هذا العدوان الذي
يجر المنطقة إلى
هاوية صراع سيطارد
الجميع صراع يواجه
خطر جدي للغاية بالتوسع